it appraised the most complex organ and
their connections that also the most
complicated ones right so and my
longtime interest was always trying to
understand neuronal communications and
and therefore this complexity risk
challenges for us to understand and one
of the ways I think and this is what we
are doing right now to was to developing
to us trying to help ourselves and also
can help the community other scientists
are the neuroscientists to understand
the neuronal communication because these
communications are really rapid right so
the cells have this sort of unique
connection and many different types so
the challenges I think is just to do our
to be better tools to help us and
therefore we are focusing an an very big
important aspect of our research was
trying to not just doing research itself
but rather than develop into as a part
of the research trying to figure out how
neurons communicate with each other
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Sathyan we are in the
beautiful Beijing China at Peking
University we are now going to be
talking about neural biology we have dr.
you long the joining us on the show are
you like hi thank you so much for coming
on the show really appreciate it
I'm also very grateful to Curie opiate
cabbage for introducing us making this
happen and for you in your lab in the
life sciences department here for
helping partner with simulation for
these great content that we're going to
have together
well ring well it's a unique opportunity
for us to thank you thank you and
hopefully we can help be a catalyst for
greater collaboration among
us/china hopefully what we hope to yes
for those that don't know you owns
background he is the principal
investigator at the School of Life
Sciences at Peking University affiliated
with the PKU McGovern brain Research
Institute
he's founder of the lead research lab
which has about 30 undergraduate and PhD
students studying cutting-edge neuro
biology and you can find the links in
the bio below you'll only lab org as
well as the Twitter and LinkedIn
profiles okay um let's start things off
with one of our favorite questions we
love asking her guests what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
well interest to us is you know if you
ask me two years ago I saw that world
will be you know better and better in
terms of collaboration you know helping
each other but right now is interest in
town but in the long run I think the
work will still you know will be better
in a way that in a people's life quality
will improve throughout the world we've
been on that upward trajectory of life
quality around the world improving which
has been great and similarly we've also
now have the democratization of all of
the exponential technologies what would
you say is some key principle to embody
as we move into the exponential
technology age well I think fundamental
research certainly will help so for
example you know the deep learning AI
that has been popular but they are I
think they are rooted from the
fundamental research the precursors and
likewise for human health the medicine
that we have been developing they are
also rooted from the generations or
years years of fundamental research like
that so
a strong first principle on fundamental
research for health and for deep
learning for pursuing the upgrades in
our world I like that a lot
how about your journey who were you
growing up where were you born
I was slung in in Fujian Province China
in the South powerful man in China and
then I spent my elementary school during
high school and senior high school there
and who I in my college year I went to
Beijing and studied in here for my
bachelor degree how did you figure out
when you were young that you wanted to
pursue science technology how did you
know well I like technology I remember
when I was young in freedom were in at
the Middle School in my fourth year our
school actually have the first computer
that for me to play and I made some
programs in fact I was very interested
in programming and and in high schools I
was also interested about chemistry and
when I at the time of trying to get to
college
in fact my first choice was trying to
study computer science in 1996 but I
fail to you know get into the class just
because my score is just not good enough
for my province and is10 she
car engine and life sciences interesting
so yeah even the funny moment of
pursuing computer science and not
getting in for that got you into life
sciences which you are now principal
investigator hell yeah and enjoy doing
that as in my brains plastic enough ok
so then so then how did you pick up what
you want to do here at picking
University and then how did you make
this move to pursue the PhD at Duke
University in the United States tell us
about those years so uh ok I you know
even though I was not in a computer
science department I was in you know
life sciences and at that time my major
was biophysics and physiology so I like
science in general then after the better
schools training I have the choices of
further of my for my education or you
know find jobs I was you know before I
graduate I was looking at raw just to
sing if I'm sort of a securing a job
with my pressure degree why is that
gonna be and I found that most of the
jobs are like salesmen which is you know
retrospective might not be bad but at
that time I something that might not fit
with my interest and I was also thinking
about to into grad school in Beijing
University prickly you at that time but
maybe the pigeon university at this in
the past was more focusing on teaching
so it's a teaching University
unlike right now we are trying to build
a worker what class research
universities so for a person who is
interested about science and research at
that time I feel you know probably I
could have better
opportunities abroad and that's high
applying grassless in the states and I
was interested about physiology
neurophysiology you know how the neurons
talk to each other and in fact when I
was applying for grad school in my
undergraduate years I was just only
focusing on your apology because I
thought that's so cool the brain is the
most complex organ in the world and
still now and understand how you work
it's just really interesting and also
understand the brain is sort of a
journey to understand ourselves because
we are all trying to you know to talk to
communicate and you know this is the the
most important organ hovering in our
body maybe even most important discovery
for us in the universe one of them yeah
yeah my Katya will agree with you yeah
but you I tend to be more politically
correct I don't say anything
oh yes
and surely quantum mechanics will have a
very big role this theory of everything
with general relativity figuring that
out figuring out the brain these things
have big roles in understanding
ourselves and sustainable building of a
future for us how about where did where
did it come up for you that you wanted
to do neurophysiology like how did that
end up being something that you were
like hmm I want to know about that well
I went to quest school at Duke
University very crew University and go
program okay I have the opportunity to
do rotations and you know including in
the labs of neurogenetics
cellular neuroscience and the sort of
experiments I do there I it's just not
as exciting at that time for me to feel
I've just few neurophysiologist most
excited because at that time we can poke
it actual to the neuronal cells and when
this neuron get in activity they were
generate action potentials and you can
really in real time seeing the waveform
of action potential generation in the
oscilloscope or your computer screens as
if you are just really talking to those
neurons and where the neuro genetics lab
that which is really good laugh but you
know we at that time we use a neural
genetic technician will generate special
genetic modified mice no cows but it
will just take like two years for you to
really know the phenotype and knowing
what happened if you eliminate this is
very important gene for the mice and
probably I'm just no patient enough to
wait for this period of time this is a
onesie to the no study you're trying to
see if you eliminate a gene what happens
over years to this because of the way to
remove this gene knocking out this gene
takes time and you know to generate this
genetically modified mice takes time and
mice you know if you want to start you
know they're in a adulthood takes time
to grow right so so it takes time and
for the cell biology at that time and I
just feel again using the technique of
immunostaining knowing you know in a
fixer what happened but I was just more
excited about in real-time how neurons
talk to each other and in fact that's
also related to my current work and in
my PA I am a postdoc to work and my
current labs work we want to study the
real time you know and how neurons talk
to each other and I think this is a you
know very challenging but a very
interesting and important yeah we'll get
into a neurotransmission we'll get into
all that or modulation so but then what
was the the PhD on and then what was the
postdoc work at Stanford on so my PhD I
work with doctor
oxygen and I was using maybe using a
unique anymore organism cos Crete and in
fact I spent quite some time in the
marine biology like a news hall where we
use the fresh screen and screen is a
really unique creature why he has this
giant neurons we're in a very famous
Nobel laureate Hawking Huxley using
scree to really understand the molecular
the mechanism of so-called action
potentials but it's giant screen neurons
also has a giant synapse where today big
are we talking this neuron compared to
like a human probably a thousand times
bigger oh um pika
why because the the diameter of linear
is the the exons is see it spins on top
but it can be 500 micron Wow but that's
just the diameter right and in our brain
our neuron in the brain excitatory
neurons the axon here is a 1 micron so
we are talking about using this giant
you know and giant synapse they have
this soka special structure synapse
where the transmitted beam Reedy's and
because this nearest peak historically
clever scientists figure out ways that
you can poke it retro into this peak
neurons and try to understand how they
react how they talk to each other
and my PhD thesis was using this
nature's gift to study the neural
communication with this giant
you know fibrous where we can poke foil
atrás - in a prison at neuro then you
don't have to sending the information to
the downstream post NAB know which also
has 3 that rose and because this e that
rose can amplify the teeny tiny current
letter january from those neurons
and then you can really read out what
happened you know during when those
noodles are talking to each other yeah
so so that was a really unique
experiences and also because of this is
marine biology lab where we use the
squid we also have a quite a number of
neighboring maps using the cliffs of
nature different gifts of nature I like
the way you put that there are there are
ways that Nature has made it easier for
us to study biology and neuroscience
that if we can find those places and
study it there it can give us better
insights into how to study it in our own
bodies right so so that gives some
nature's so that was jus disa t truce
truce and by scientists you know
different animal model systems included
not just in the neuro snore system but
also during the environment freedom you
can use the sea urchins there to study
the development and you can start you
can use the goldfish to study how the
auditory pathway integration because it
turns out the coffee she has this giant
also neurons that integrate is auditory
improves to illustrate some escape
behaviors and so that was a sort of an
interesting you know we're just seeing
how people were really using different
sort of motor systems to study there are
very questions and also frequently the
fundamental understanding that we obtain
using screen using go fish sea urchin
that turns out to be conserved through
our species including human cells and
but because of nature's gift their
unique structure unique size or their
simplicity of anatomy really allow us
much easier to probe their secrets then
one can use those known
principles derived from those simple
addict insistence trying to understand
in a more complex organisms life in
including human in human diseases and I
will also say just to elaborate a little
bit more even if a sentence you found
the principles derive from squee from
sea urchin as I mentioned are not
conserved
to memos to humans but you can still
provide interesting diversity for
example how really nature solve the
problem you know to enable vision right
even if the maybe the squeezed eyes are
different than humans but the the the
principle after you really understood
understanding that then can help you to
appreciate how nature use diversity
fight mechanism to solve the same
problem for example to detect in light
and and sometimes you can also find out
that the same principle maybe was no use
in in the video system but my user
Allison's resistant so the the
meticulous person has a students of even
though the the system is different ok
when you're giving the example of these
nature's gifts and how they can you can
find potentially neurons a thousand
times the size of human neurons for me
it was kind of funny beginning to you
know start thinking about where are all
these nature gifts and how do we start
understanding them better and
scientifically researching them but also
it came up this idea that you're a
neuron and I'm a neuron and our words
are the neurotransmission what probably
it's probably more complicated than that
it's just it was an interesting analogy
that that came to mind how about what
was going on
and for the cutting-edge tools for
understanding mapping that neural
modulation that neural activity but also
you said you know I'm trying to envision
here you know you guys having these two
electrodes for it on two on each neuron
there and also trying to see what's
happening in the synapse trying to see
what is actually going on with the
neurotransmission how are you how are
you visualizing that how are you
actually being able to record it and
learn from it
well the most classical approaches
people develop that probably 150 years
oh it's using the glass electrode as I
mentioned while you can poke loss in
actual then it has these teeny tiny tips
so when you are poking the adapter into
the neuronal cells hoping that the cells
are still healthy and has teeny tiny
hole but no damage and that we are
connecting the the cells with the glass
it actual and what you also have a
crusted actual that it that you insert
amplifier that can amplify the current
that the leaking off so the cell okay
and then the way to understand you know
communication is then you can record
those teeny tiny currents that was
generated - one is near on receiving the
presynaptic info receiving the improve
on the sender cells that's the most
classical approach which is still being
used one of the challenges is you need
to be really skillful and also you
better to have that animal or land
neuron to be sitting still right because
this class it also are so that it
dedicate you know just since I'm moving
are just scratching
sales memory in a cell which is by yeah
and also the supa luv that approaches in
the only can recall most likely one cell
attack so it's lower super yeah which is
now in the hundreds of neurons at a time
hope as well so so imaging in our regard
that will be useful because if you have
a spatial resolution you can impair er
just like this video you can just take
an image of what happened we haven't
seen a since and in fact around a time
people have already generated dyes to
try to do can neuronal communication yes
there's a special dye called ëthe and I
that is being used in the field and this
F&I has this unique property that once
you incorporate into the membrane you
will be become frozen
so some clever scientists then they just
pull off I also have a cell and it's
stimulate those new and your own useless
west coast to read each transmitter
but once the best cop in release you
will merge with the surface membrane and
therefore the dye which is sort of
attached to it and after the transmitter
been released
neural also used this Soha endocytosis
or internalization process will take
down the time and therefore this time
would just be this artificial dye that
it would just be taking out into the
vesicle and why you do is you just wash
out the rest of the plasma membrane time
you only retain the time in those
vesicles that contain transmitters and
then you can just use the camera to look
at how those dyes that is being released
the fluorescing the fluorescence january
for most eyes in different colors could
be in different colors and that's been
in a powerful wage again using image
masses to look at how to tells me to
print release but you are actually not
exactly looking at transmitters
but looking at
the tie as a pseudo transmitter yeah and
similar principle has also been extended
she using a green force and 14 it's hot
GFP and you can take advantage of Santa
Fe has a unique pH sensitivity and
therefore you can engineer this genetic
in holy protein to tag it to those teeny
tiny vesicle contain transmitters and
there's Wesker it is actually known to
be very acidic because they contain the
protons that does the energy currency to
generate the to load those transmitters
and therefore this GFP if they are not
been released so in touch with is to
know what they will be deemed because
they are pinched by this acidic
environment but once you really fuse
with the plasma membrane The Outsider is
pH neutral and then the Jaypee will just
be bright and you can just see the
signal force in signal increase so
that's also P news and those are all
efforts people are trying to you know
complement the class it actual or
electrophysiology message trying to
understand how neon totally child:yeah
an expansion microscopy is also a big
one especially my kospi pioneer by my
friend ed Boyden in MIT that's us
there's a different ways not just to
look at neuronal communication in real
time but instead I think maybe but also
powerful in a way to look at how neuron
connect with each other in structure
because of the as I mentioned the
neuronal connections are through this
unique structure synapse and nerves are
teeny-tiny in our brain so the expansion
microscopy when ed Boyden
was developing was really
enlarge the size of those neurons clear
cells well-maintained maintaining their
morphology and their geometry and
therefore you will allow one to
visualize which neuron connects to which
new and helping us to build a blueprint
of understanding then you know in
Atomics and you can also be combined
with some special medical abacus so we
normally know the neuronal morphology
but we also know which type of neuron
they they might be a sort of a secret
Gautam a secret Kappa of sitri dopamine
yeah and then how about the trains how
about the transition for the postdoc
work at Stanford you know how did you
went to the other coast you were able to
explore California able to see that and
what were you doing there so interesting
so I would just stand for Provost I was
also a little bit by Aston so I was
attending a society of neurosis meeting
when I was a grad student and I was
presently a poster poster if I remember
correctly and my postdoc advisor diction
or Richardson he was a professor at
Stanford at that time he was just
passing by my poster and because I been
a grad student I know his work and and I
liked his work and so he was just
passing by my poster so I I actually I
think he just like stare at my poster
for like 10 second or 15 seconds about
to leave and I was jumping out of the
crowd grabbed him and just having some
thoughts about you know trying to talk
to him and maybe impressing and seeking
some
postdoctoral position opportunities and
and did was kind enough and so he he was
not offended by my rudeness and so
actually I got to talk to him and
originally you're jumping out of the
crowd a her grabbing her yeah yeah I
could be more wagon all right so so at
the end he was very generous and nice
and in a way so we talked and then he
invited me to interview at Stanford and
then after interview he actually gave me
the offer and in fact the Excite is the
only that I interview and and and I
decided she I liked the lab I decided to
go and so I went to Stanford what we
seen and also actually trying to
understand more how neuronal
communication occurs was the molecular
mechanism and how to visualize just
following why I said before this
communication yeah and then how about
then the transition back to making
University to be the principal
investigator here in the life sciences
how did that happen well being a poster
for quite some time you know post is a
temporary job right so I think both my
wife and I we are both in a sign
scientists we will post post I staff at
that time so we were thinking about you
know after post our training and what
would be the next move right we are post
are still very into research into trying
to understand how things work and I I
was also thinking about jobs in the
state
okay I should happen to have some
faculty job offers and also at that time
also by Aston
or coincidence that my PhD advisor was
hosting one of the symposia
international biophysics meeting in
China in Beijing so he wrote to me you
know knowing that I'm was working on
some aspect of research in neuronal
communication and incur me whether I was
interested in to attending the symposium
his organizing in in Beijing and I was
not carrying my fly fly fares okay but
but I could sort of cover my long gene
and you know we've waived
the conference registration fee and just
you know because I was in Beijing
starting for quite some time and haven't
been back for some time so I was I was
thinking oh that's a you know to
opportunity just to you know visit in
Beijing and you know just check since
our yeah and since I was an
undergraduate student in Beijing and big
University University so I was inquiry
some of the faculties here and just
thinking about you know how is the
university doing and how is the life
sciences research and in fact I also got
good encouragement from my pool I would
say mentor which no staff or faculty
that I crave rituals and so it turns out
that my trip to Beijing then become post
attending for the the conference in that
I was given talk but also I arranged in
a way that I visited him back picking
University
and giving a job talk and I guess that
jaw Chuck went well so I called a job
offer from Peking University and and and
I think we we were debating because we
were been in the States for that close
3,000 years and and also there's good
science there we are we are we were
familiar with the fund insists and you
know how to set in our lab sort in a
teach in English but I on the other half
I was thinking about the opportunities
here I feel that this is also a unique
opportunity where you can get into
society into a university aware that
this rappy sort of change or rise in
terms of the academia research accompany
the economic component and comparing
with the states even though the I would
say the derivative the increased rates
higher than the states but a total mass
of the two scientists or the preparation
for the two research are still tiny by
comparison with the states and therefore
being a society here if you make
positive progress that you potentially
could have I think larger impacts and
that is one of the incentives and the
other incentive was I think that we have
quite to students because I was a
student here and we also have
good grass support because in globally
around him because of the financial
downturn starting from 2008 and that
issue was causing recent troubles for
scientists as well and I feel that a lot
of scientists including ones in the
States and some other places just
because of the economic downturn they
are just more spending time trying to
really secure funding to keep their lab
alive
instead of focusing on trying to force
us and efforts into research and into
making research progress and and in
Beijing potentially it could provide
this unique opportunity so that was my
son and also I would say part of its
just being naive okay and I because you
know in fact I have no I you know I have
not been there for you know more than 10
years I actually don't know exactly how
this funding system works like once in
Chinese and but I was I'm just naive
enough and taking a risk and I thought
maybe since we'll just work out okay and
and my students they don't know that
right so gracious in naively you know
work with me and it's maybe thinking I'm
just really a figure always since out
but I was still sort of trying to source
inside as well
yeah so the the factors of the big
university growths plus the big economic
growth plus you being just naive enough
to be like I'll figure out how to write
grants and Chinese out and back
being and figure that out so so you take
this role and then you started
introducing us to this and I really like
how you put it because it's important to
get behind the eyes of these principal
investigators or these lab directors
because in many ways the students that
are coming in to work in the lab are a
look equipment a look we can conduct our
science no problem but get behind the
eyes of you who had to put together all
of the grant applications all of the
funding to be able to buy the equipment
to make conducting the science easy so
there's a lot of nuance in this
operational process when you teach us
about what that's been like for you
interesting so in fact when I was in
grad school and as opposed to I was
supposed I was imposed relative sort of
establishing faculties that so I myself
did not witness how lab start from
scratch so so that's actually in fact a
lot of learning curves for me just and
also in a environment in Beijing which I
I did not get my PhD trained Ian my
postdoc training so that that quite a
lot of since that especially at the
beginning Tinoco well I remember like
like in the first two years that once
you know yet
you know some of ourselves get
contaminated you know and I was talking
to myself
students are all good but they are
lacking experience and then there's just
there's a lot of nitty-gritty details
pose of in terms of equipment lab skills
you know be careful and just a lot of
sense to her and I was talking to myself
I was like oh my goodness I cannot make
it here because you know there's just
massive works right
so so but I guess you know since
eventually workout and I assume I have
good students and I really sink them
they are fearless oh not if okay so they
are free this day they work with me they
you know so you know even though we met
a lot of troubles in because we are
doing research you know if you think
about research three such right this is
the common scene that's just a lot of
free Diaz but I think they are and my
students they are energetic and and in a
way we also have a good University
support we already have a good critical
mass of two scientists and who south and
are more senior than me but a lot a lot
of Lynnae have the similar there they
are similar age and then we shared our
experience and then we help each others
and so we got no support in fact at
least initially I did not put a lot of
efforts into writing grants but trying
to source out just to you know eliminate
a contamination problem for the cell
yeah in a molecular biology doesn't work
problem that the camera is just broken
problem so I was more focusing on that
then how did you end up figuring out the
vision of being this principal
investigator in life sciences
what do you leave you know biology being
the code of life and there's so much
complexity across all of it neuroscience
we're talking about the complexity of
the brain and has such an incredible
organ for us to understand how do you
figure out the vision how do you figure
out where to allocate resources how do
you figure all this out so indeed
it appraised the most complex organ and
their connections are also the most
complicated ones right so and my don't I
interest was always trying to understand
neuronal communications and and
therefore this complexity risk
challenges for us to understand and one
of the ways I think and this is what we
are doing right now to was to develop
into us trying to help ourselves and
also can help the community other
scientists are the neuroscientists to
understand the neuronal communication
because these communications are really
rapid right so the cells have this sort
of unique connection and many different
types so the challenges I think is just
to developing better tools to help us
and therefore we are focusing and an
very big important aspect of our
research was trying to not just doing
research itself but rather than
developing cure as a part of the
research trying to figure out how
neurons communicate with each other
and one of the ways just follow our
previous conversation was trying to
develop interest that can enable
parallel detection or enable detection
with spatial resolution and that
realized you know as most of you're all
aware of imaging right now videos that
has this sort of a spatial resolution
and also if when work the scenes from
from a different angle because of
neurons are in the brain are so complex
there are so many different types if we
can figure our way to label those neuron
with specificity
Amida light then in the dark we can just
see those lies and that can help us and
one of the best way to label those cells
with specificity is to again rely on
nature's principle nature's gift that's
using the DNA using those sort of DNA
inside a cell to encode those labels and
using the genetic program inside of
cells to turn on those light tendinous
label in a specific cell type okay
in fact this principle has already been
used quite some time by different
scientists in a few not just for
neuroscience but also for development
right so then the the Challenger will be
if you want to develop this sort of so
hot genetic encode he was at the control
of label in the DNA and you also want to
develop something that it will emit
light right then how do you make those
scenes sensitive to the secret language
neuron communicate with each other
I know release different chemicals to
activate their downstream targets so
then the question becomes how do you
design a way to pull off special protein
which are genetically encoded by DNA
which is so the amiright so you can
borrow from for example jellyfish has
the screen for supporting all-powerful
fireflies which they have this new
series which will emit light and but you
want to make them also not only just
email diaper also email I only in the
presence of this secret neural chemicals
in those individual cells
right and so that's why we were working
on when I was sitting on my map and so
one more time to see if we get this
straight so then it's the engineering of
the protein which then goes into the
neuron which then is able to enable the
neuron to for is to be able to showcase
what which neural chemicals are coming
and then it's you can detect yeah and
and it's through a fluorescence process
and it can be a specific color of
fluorescence for a specific neural
chemical different colors or different
light intensity right in different
verses is one way the other one
luciferase is not for sense but is a
sort of peyote luminances it's using
this chemical energy to generalize but
difference between forces and pyro
dominance are the forces required
excitation light and then they usually
will emit a longer witness of life
that's for instance the power
illuminations from fireflies right we
don't use in light to illuminate those
fireflies
but the fireflies in attack they were
just in me life because they use those
chemical energies that were just so
chemical reaction catalyzed by this
Lucifer is this enzyme now which is emit
photons how do you get the neuron to not
reject the genetically engineered
protein so that has already been worked
out by many others it always works now
the neuron never rejects now they're
that different ways we are using these
model organisms that yes this genetic
techniques has already been worked out
by many scientists so so you have you
can specifically designed genetic tools
to allow fire flies fruit flies or
zebrafish
or mice
to express this piece of DNA but none
tastic DNA yeah yeah yeah getting past
the immune response is critical and okay
and now it's about being able to map
neural communication using these
techniques so what so then at the lab
then how how are you working by with the
different undergraduate and PhD students
how is there some sort of a lab
communication that you do for figuring
out where to understand neural
communication what resources are going
into which of the buckets well it
depends on at which stage so for the
initial stage for example we are just
scratching our heads are just trying to
see for example the principle I
mentioned that we are trying to develop
developing this genetic encoding sensors
that can express it in ourselves we we
don't have anything working yet so so we
have a group of students that really
focusing just trying to test you know
again we also take advantage of nature's
gift harness how nature detectors new
chemicals okay and the freedom of a
hijacking or tap into nature's so called
receptors it is a major have a different
receptors since in those neural
chemicals like dopamine or ester calling
or good to me and then we really rely on
nature's designs this molecule once they
interact with of receiving the message
these chemicals they will undergo some
conformational change that has
structural change and we were
painstakingly testing if we put a
light-emitting green fluorescent protein
there may be the structure changes can
lead to the ability to email a change so
at the beginning it was just you know
sort of slow tedious and and we was
really focusing on that after five or
six years after we actually are pretty
good at this we figure out some generic
way so that we can make this to work and
we actually figure out the ways that can
make image notice green light but you
know red line otherwise okay
and we also figure out through our
optimization that we can that an even
more last bright lights rather than
right dim lights and therefore that the
lab now it's different than at the
beginning because once we have in the
sudha its promise we figure those things
out the lab now we are sort of dividing
a set of different questions that we
asked using different sensors we that we
design and development will not only
have those trees that we distribute to
some other fellow scientists but we also
use this first available to us and pull
them in the brain freedom in fruit fly's
brain and just trying to decode how the
fruit fly when they since flower banana
what happened to that brain yes and
there are neurochemical important neural
chemical and interesting enough fruit
fly share a lot of common important
neural chemicals just like humans like
hundreds territories in the other way
it's similar to when we see a banana we
get some sort of excitement realizes why
they you are they have different neural
Anatomy but you know so presumably
natural seduction they are also very
sensitive to their banana order right
because there's there's a source of food
nicer days so they evolve to detect it
with sensitivity right so then we can
look at for example what happens with
their fruit flies serotonin now haha and
because we have the tools that we can
really look at we are it will be release
and how is the related to their sort of
a physiology function in fact before us
in a people already know the serotonin
is a very important neural chemical and
a human brain is actually data to
depression right so the FDA approved
drugs that target certain assistants for
therapeutic effects and now we have
those tools which we can look at for
full flies mice and we just for
curiosity we do K since it's simple
right and freedom is known that fruit
flies also they led they remember they
can associate with some in a full food
order with some in a good approaching
behaviors and serotonin is infant Rises
also very important if you somehow
eliminate serotonin do not allow it to
secretly they don't remember from right
don't remember and now we have this unit
to then we can just look at fruit flies
brain try to understand this teeny tiny
creature why certain is important where
do they secrete and how fast they
secrete secret at which cells and how to
see radicular learning ability this
teeny tiny creature might have and in
hoping that our understanding my share
lies of human physiology or disease in
the future we don't know yet but at
least Israel just be interesting I hope
my student will be curious enough just
to understand that you
and then what how do you how do you do
that the imaging of such faint light for
something like their serotonin secretion
in a fruit fly
how are you doing that imaging such a
small creature again yeah
you should ask my students they are the
one doing its partners so this had a
challenge because of full-fare so
teeny-tiny right so my students they
figure out a way and in fact there are
other scientists also in a work on
surprise is a pretty popular anymore
model organism especially for genetics
for development studies what because is
grow really fast and has a lotta gene
available genetic tools but for full
fries we sort of carefully any surprise
them and martlin using cells
non-invasive glue to mountain on certain
paper or in a clean paper or something
and then we can pull in under a very
sophisticated microscope that people
have been developing for years and his
microscope that it's called two-photon
microscope and this microscope has this
unique ability that you can sort of
using the longer wavelengths of light
that it can reach relative deeper into
the brain just to see since okay and
therefore we can just sort of
non-invasively not the fly are still
alive and then you can still you know
give them different orders and if you
see the their legs they are still sort
of a ran in using long wave lengths of
the illumination line right then more
than a thousand nanometer line right our
eyes can you see us right in in that can
send you the imaging
that's happening right that you can sort
of scan point by point and just Gladys
point by point signal together you have
an imaging and then you can also scan
over time that will create movies when
you bring the banana you watch the
neural activity there on vacation yes
yes okay and I can see all of the
interesting applicability and insights
that that actually gives into our own
neurophysiology and all the other
creatures with nervous systems what
about your ideal tool what would be your
ideal neural science tool for achieving
this desire for understanding neural
communication what would be a tool that
you imagine as this epic pinnacle tool
that could be so great for us well I
think you know if you think about to us
in general right the truest you do will
be the tools that allow us to manipulate
things that will also be true that allow
us to recall since I don't read these to
generate general categories right so the
neuro system is so complex and in a way
the idea to if I could think about and
again people are trying to do that but
it's still not available yet if you have
an idea to for animal studies that you
can simultaneously control you know a
hundred different have neurons activity
using orthogonal right don't interfere
with each other and then you also have
the master can simultaneously reading
our a hundred different type of neurons
activity and knowing which ties which
time or secondly then this can really
for understand how neuron compute this
can provide power to up
because then you can read it out in the
native condition what happened with lost
neuronal activities you can read read
out in the disease condition in animal
models or happen with different type of
neurons and then then picking out or is
this type that went wrong not the other
way and but that only provides you the
correlations right because we are just
reading out the during this scene what
happened
then the tools that can allow you
simultaneously computery know certainly
control is a hundred have neurons
activity then you can really precisely
just to perturb those neurons of inches
and then just Chinese led to establish a
causality and that would be the you know
perfect ruler to help to understand in
the intact system those neuronal
functions and you will have a long I
think
implications of understanding the
disease causes and provide therapeutic
approaches in a long run
okay so again this is gonna be
challenging but this will be very useful
and that being said for humans there
will be even more challenging
I just because of the you know ethical
issues and then the it's just even more
challenging to to do that in humans and
maybe just an overlap artist if one can
do that with an animal models in clean
up human primaries and now already be
very useful for the neuro sisters I like
that too a lot and
how about on a
neural communication level of disease
many people especially cyber Natisha
ng's talk about how every disease that
we experience is a disease of
communication that's happening within
the body howdy
what do you feel about that statement
and then how do you feel about the onset
of things like neuro degeneration
related to miss functional neural
communication well indeed a lot of
diseases are so due to cell-cell
communication problems okay in fact if
you look at a FDA approved drugs they
are about probably a 40% to 50% are
directly or indirectly targeting to this
cut sort of protein receptor protein car
GPCR g-protein couple receptors which
are sitting on the cell membrane
receiving the input from other cells and
then talk to the illness power of the
cell ask them to do since okay and the
drugs currently available are targeting
those surface receptors forty to fifty
percent of them and and using them to
given some better instructions something
are over activated you just the drugs
just people inquire thousand are weak
activate the drugs just you know
activated activated in a better stress
and that provides the therapeutic value
for a lot of patients so just by that
definition probably about 50 percent of
those this is are really related to the
cell cell communication not just knows
the the
fat cells the heart cells they're also
having those receptors and since in the
homes and and then and then I think in
that regard there's also other
opportunities to further sort of design
drugs and hockey those protein for
therapeutic purpose for example in human
genome they are probably around a
hundred of those cheap VCRs are still
often meaning that they we don't know
why is their indulgences weaken the
physical relevant even to activate it
and never we have full understanding of
their function even though for every
sense of evidence we could case they are
important but we don't know what kinda
sense make sense what is their
physiological function and therefore we
do know right now offer a really
therapeutic target for active animal but
with their fundamental research it
freedom of the organized and identify
their physical written and understand
the pathophysiology function they can
provide more pockets that again aiming
at the receiving end right pre has those
the other is the receptors receiving and
again for therapeutic purpose and we can
also tag it at the signal sending em
right sending the information right you
can prevent as the search would be over
accurate isn't in a wrong signal or you
can you know sort of a post sending of
the signal right now there are some
drugs to inhabit still relative feel and
I think there are more opportunities in
narita but probably it requires
especially for the nervous system it
requires our better understanding which
there is doing what because it to really
have a therapeutic effects you want to
pour
the relevant signal communication and
minimize this tacky effect but right now
because of complexity of the neurosystem
only for the tip of iceberg subset of
cells of brain regions we have some
understanding of their physiology and
pathophysiology flows for the majority I
was in more than 90 percent or 95
percent of the brain region and with
specific cells we actually have no idea
of their function we don't even know you
know the blueprint connectomics of the
human neurons yet because of it is so
complex and and so so there are still
requirements and incentives for for
scientists and for the society with
governmental support private foundation
support trying to sort of help us to
understand the fundamentals the basic
research in hoping to provide
therapeutic more therapeutic
interventions I love that that also ties
us to that first thing that you said
about the fundamental scientific
research being done and it can help
enable so much of the therapeutic
effects that we soon want and need what
about neural prosthetics I'm curious
about what your thoughts are about that
field and about jamming chips into our
brains what do you think about that well
I think it's a very unique and promising
area right that's already fda-approved
therapeutic approaches to deep brain
stimulation for certain diseases and
and neuroprosthetics will be a better
wait to help to buy integrate sensory
information and to feed back to the the
linear or specific type neurons that
freedom who in principle enable at least
establish those disabled persons to have
a better control of their lives and also
has implications of you know enhance the
human ability sports ability compact
ability which might not be the direction
we want to talk creative ability
possibly I think right now I think it's
promising but there are still high
peaceful on why no not that you get in a
way how to really implement those things
with regenerate designs of whether I can
predict if you're doing this that it
will have this beneficial value I think
in this is still a work in progress
yes does it ever feel like we have a
little way to figure out some of our
ethical or moral challenges first before
jamming the chips into our brains or
cosa we need to consider of human status
Ness this ethical concern the ethical
issues need to be we are thought up and
discuss and in fact you know since goes
through waves for example you know just
as time for many years ago when
scientists first invent ways to generate
recombinant DNA that's already serious
discussion about the implication of this
tech
and now is this genome editing CRISPR
caste system that can have a higher
efficiency to edit genes with will this
Educare is another wave but it's
actually since that of sort of ethical
concern and rigor need to need to be
exercised and need to be discussed and
and also is a it's a I think it's not
just for one country and it's also
global international efforts and it's
challenging in a way that it also
integrates with different cultural
differences okay
so well I'm not a clinical scientist
working on human subject or se but it is
right now for us working on animal
models that we have less sort of
concerns right now but for the
therapeutic purpose one all-cause need
to think in other months like how you
put it that this is important on our
whole geopolitical on a global level and
there are cultural differences that need
to be accounted for all of this type of
stuff the current state of our world as
you mention at the beginning is going in
the direction of prosperity maximizing
flourishing making meeting the basic
needs of people all this type of stuff
yet we have the most massive gap in
wealth inequality ever what do you think
about that
Wow it's a big question
[Music]
let's see well I think some fundamental
sort of rights for example rights to
have a good education that my help in a
way so to sort of reduce this imbalance
okay
and you know China for example you know
just like many countries including in
States there's also huge regional
differences right so for example in
China there's usually a longer cost more
economic d'Ivoire and therefore are
having good a relatively good resources
for education and healthcare etc and in
in West countryside and there will be
just best but in terms of the education
as a fundamental right just to to make
it happen to everyone and with with
guarantee support I think that can help
to reduce the impetus and also more than
technique-wise
right so for example the the the cell
phone cell phones are being very popular
in a way that has the internet
connection has a network and in China is
been popular that can be use for almost
every single scene you know are they pay
and
we chatting implement the infrastructure
sort of a relatively equally meaning
that allowed the SS of cellphone signal
in every single corner of the country
will be useful photos that's developing
countries because then they have access
to the connected world to for
information for education for you know
convenient East Services and the capital
or sort of the economic weather itself
might not do it because of you know
economic wise for the cellphone company
it probably will be more beneficial to
install the cell phone towers in the
dense population tensions well well
economically makes sense and therefore I
think governmental or charity private
sectors in a way trying to counter the
pure economic drive but sort of imprints
the basic infrastructure the education
rights to every corner Anna and I
mentioned are probably also not in China
but in other countries there's always
this economic drive led to make profits
that piss on you know developed country
developed cities or certain generations
certain idol groups but how to really
implement the infrastructure that a
counter this profit driven market force
I think it will be important in to
ensure the sort of the path
and the reduce of this huge gap for the
different classes yeah I like that
answer a lot figuring out how to
democratize education around the world
and how to create incentives for that
democratization I like that a lot
and with the explosion of exponential
technologies that are happening right
now especially at your lab this is
really interesting how do you and your
students in the lab keep up with
neurobiological research that's
happening in China in the United States
around the world how do you keep up with
all of the advances that are happening
well we use posts I would say
old-fashioned ways and also use new
technology ways right so old-fashioned
ways where we read papers so the the
scientific publications are still the
problem one of the oldest way are still
a very valuable way to communicate your
ideas and your sort of inventions so we
have our regular journal clubs that we
reach sort of research articles relevant
to our interest we also attend it could
research conferences and post in China
and abroad including inner states
Society of neuroses meetings probably
the largest meeting for the
neuroscientists and
we almost every year we've been there
and more than three students that are
from mine they go there we also use the
social media right the for example which
has been popular in China and they are
some special in Chinese come somehow and
there's sort of a certain sort of a
special group that will collect some of
those latest development they do the
broadcast through which and we can
subscribe and also there is as private
sectors there's some individual research
groups for example if they are in our
own field they also create our own
private WeChat sort of a group that they
disseminate their general crap okay they
are sauce about certain paper certain
techniques and we also join the
discussion and subscribe and and in fact
we also embrace ourselves for example we
use bio archive you know which you sort
of review our pre pre pre in research
previous official sort of publication so
in a way that the scientists will have a
early access to South our research and
how that has a Twitter account and some
students are managing many for our
research and discoveries and and I'm
also hoping to have a better investment
of sort of our own website and have a
better updates and also with our own
groups cons on how the South my students
if you listen please help me to do that
yeah I like the variety of techniques
and processes that you described there
and I'm happy to hear that there's these
groups that are happening within things
like WeChat where they're compressing
the the scientific discoveries and
imitating them through the platform to
other people and getting more people
engaged I like that a lot
also in this exponential technology age
what would be something you'll have a
child six years old yes yes and we have
many people that have children what is
something that they can learn going into
this exponential technology that you
think is a critical skill to learn I I
wish he is not addicted to iPad okay I
think it's a little bit too much so Wow
Wow what we meaning me and my wife while
we are trying to do is actually getting
into an old-fashioned way to read books
so essentially what we are trying to do
is come to this machi force or this
attractiveness of iPad which is a
colorful app with this sound with this
cartoon but in a way trying to kick in
to read books honestly speaking I don't
have a good solution okay so so right
now I'm really forcing a way to buy this
like five minutes
iPad equals five pages of book books oh
so she has to read five pages before he
can ask for five minutes of iPad but
probably you know I could get more
advice from others and it's been
challenging for me yeah yeah yeah then
there may be some sort of really
interesting aspects to old principled
ways of learning like reading books that
are just really critical to knowledge
accumulation that we may not be able to
get from iPads but also vice versa
certain things that we can get from the
newest technological revolutions that we
could get from the older technologies
does it feel like
there's some sort of meaning to this big
human experiment that we're all a part
of on this planet what is the meaning of
it
I don't know I hate I don't think about
a lot about that but they're from you
know that there are a lot of sauce right
just looking at not just human right you
know they're sauce that and even as
books called the self selfish DNA right
so so one of the meaning if you put it
this way as a creature as a biological
species is we just spin see that in a
way that we need to pass our pass on our
genetic material to our offsprings right
and yeah I probably should think more
about that and you know if I have less
grad students to worry about you know we
have a a a amount of computational
capacity that is now starting to become
more and more able to do simulations
digital twins all these kinds of things
does it feel like we're in a simulation
again I I don't think about this I I
hope not
when I was reading or learning some
simulation new jury the other part of my
brain is how can I pull this to help my
students like or help our research
projects that where we can using this
computation power that has been
generated for example including deep my
or as they have this Africa but also
they have this aha thought which is a a
program to help to try to predict
protein structures I probably put more
sort of how to use this
simulation instead of worrying about you
know doing in artificial intelligence
that we to do ever since but how to
harness like a far fort or similar
programs to provide predicting essays or
predicting structures that can help our
research or help our understanding of
the brain that's why I'm probably most
source of that yes yes the creative
capacity of super intelligence to run
all the permutations and find the ones
that are most relevant is so important
well I wish it I could find one and it
is to solve our structural biology
problem okay I you know I'm trying to
learn a little bit myself but it's too
challenging for me I'm too old does it
feel like consciousness arises from the
biological complexity does it feel like
it comes from somewhere it takes the
seat in the bone yeah yeah I I think so
you know just looking at again the
nervous system from you know if we
define those different animal species
right so you can look at the scenes from
some simple actions like see Eric on the
Arrogant Worms
or Drosophila there are a lot of sort of
fundamental neuronal connections at the
to cell level might be the same but
across the the human beings or primates
that really have this expansion of this
complexity that enable more
sophisticated
control and that is correlated with
higher cognitive function including you
know depression happiness you know you
know all different emotions emphasis it
right so yeah I think that research to
correlation and the causality is always
challenging to to prove what is the role
of love in life well
I think it is to make people help you
you know we have again we have a six
year self for our family and you know
he's for sure the source of joy just you
know even though fighting him not to get
addicted to iPad right so it's you know
it's just really a source of joy just
thinking you know making mistakes in a
dream city scenes or you know or really
pretend to be an ATAR to be a loving
person and you know giving greetings
yes you know I think the the in are
regarded Duffy's just make people happy
and what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
well it is right now the center of
gravity for me or my family is our stop
okay so the with the keys actually you
know I think this is a special
relationship ending just seeing and I
think this is I think it is
irreplaceable yeah yeah The Selfish Gene
yeah procreation but it's also such a
central source of love and enlightened
joy and beauty yeah
well this has been really fun all right
you Wow good to talk to you yeah all
right thank you so much for coming on
the show sure thanks for bringing us out
to the picking University really okay
did it well I hope I hope South my
students see or don't see either wait I
will be happy if you see this you please
help me do something okay if you don't
that's okay I don't feel the
embarrassment I love it thank you
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear thoughts
in the comments below in the episode let
us know what you're thinking have more
conversations with your friends families
co-workers people online about
neurobiology and about all these tools
that we were describing today in the
episode also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the leaders around the
world do you believe in support them
help them grow support our show
simulation you can find all of our links
below for support and also check out the
links in the bio to support your lonely
lab org also the Twitter profile for the
lab as well as you lungs LinkedIn
profile and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon
bye
peace